here is droopy last night matter I can't
believe it used to lock me up in the
glorified chicken coop chicken coop
those are procedurally generated clouds
bet that river is a rainbow literally
I'm putting real elbow grease into this
place you're supposed to put elbow
grease into your daughter dad makes the
toilet look like r2d2 and it breaks the
front page of Reddit but I'm Charles
Manson because I gave you your own world
instead of an iPad
hey everybody knew Rick and Morty were
finally learning about Rick's history
when he was gone supposedly during this
20-year period and what Beth did while
he was away in what happened to his wife
so there are a couple clues that we've
gotten across the series the way that
Beth talks about him now that he's back
the way that Rick talks about his wife
as well as this sort of cynical take on
love and marriage weddings especially
back at the end of season two so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I do Rick and Morty every week there'll
be giveaway stuff at the end of the
video but just starting with this clip
we learned that fruit peel and is
basically an alternate dimension that
Rick has co-opted and turned into like a
beach city from Steven universe or
something from adventure time just a
place for Beth as a child to be where
she could be completely safe in the
whole comedy of it is it's just most to
be Rick's idea of what a little girl
would want but obviously Beth is super
pissed off because she wanted her father
to be around so it seems like it's more
of a glorified daycare when he was away
fighting the government because you know
a lot of people wonder what was he doing
for those 20 years we learn a little bit
about that through bird person's
character back during season one and
season two about the wars that they
fought together presumably over a long
period of time you know you're not being
very supportive a bird person on his big
day bird person's big day Morty was at
Blood Ridge on clap flats third mood
against the crop the mites this this is
a losing battle is your intention to
abandon Rick using his own portal gun in
bird culture this is considered a dick
move birdperson you always stick up for
Rick but he doesn't care about anyone
but himself he doesn't think about the
consequences of anything he does and as
a result he has the power to save or
destroy entire worlds and he is the
reason you and I know each other and the
reason I'm alive at all
[Music]
what's that who's that baby those are
the types of situations you would need
to put your daughter in a special
alternate dimension to protect her like
this so they talk about blood rage like
it's Band of Brothers just this is awful
things that they experienced but Beth
doesn't know a whole lot about it so I
think that's just the confirmation that
that's what Rick was doing he was just
fighting the government for all those
years but we know that she didn't spend
all of her time in this special
alternate space because she met Jerry in
high school got pregnant early and you
can make a lot of theories about why
she's stuck with Jerry but it's pretty
clear based on her therapy sessions and
factoring pickle Rick that she has
textbook abandonment issues so even
though it seems like she kind of
despises Jerry because he's so pathetic
she also loves him because he's stuck
around and he cares about her genuinely
the other thing to consider too is what
happened to Rick's wife because we got
that false memory back during season 3
episode 1 we just don't know which parts
of it are true
I'll explain I have a theory about that
as well when we talk about Rick's wife
did you make a breakthrough sort of I
just took a long look at myself and I
don't think this science thing is gonna
pay off well why don't I get Beth and
we'll go out for ice cream that Diane is
the last great idea that will ever be
had in this garage so way back during
the first season Rick actually talks
about love marriage is a more general
conversation they're having where he's
just using it to snipe on Jerry but you
listen to what he says and it actually
sounds like his marriage fell apart
probably because he was away so much
listen Morty I hate to break it to you
but what people call love it's just a
chemical reaction that compels animals
to breed it hits hard Morty then it
slowly fades leaving you stranded in a
failing marriage I did it your parents
are gonna do it break the cycle Morty
rise above focus on science so then now
think about this clip here he puts Beth
in this special space because she's a
little girl can't take care of herself
and he wants to protect her but under
normal circumstances when you're in a
two-parent household when one parent has
to go away you just stay with the other
parent so if she was just left to fend
for herself in this crazy rainbow plays
you can assume that at a very young age
her mother was gone one of a couple ways
their marriage fell apart she
went away she either died or something
happened and Rick put her in some other
alternate place so like at the end of
the unity episode he showed that he
could actually affect himself in every
single dimension every version of Rick
with a single act I think we can assume
that no matter whether she left Rick or
she died Rick definitely did something
to affect all of his wives across the
multiverse we've been to so many
different realities we should have
bumped into a version of her or at least
seen a picture of her so it's very clear
that Rick did something to protect her
or keep her out of sight out of mind
otherwise he'd be thinking about her all
the time but that's why I think that
this fake scene this fake memory is even
more heartbreaking because if she'd been
killed and that was the reason why he
joined the council of ricks that would
be really sad but it wouldn't be as
heartbreaking as if she left him is much
easier to deal with a revenge scenario
you killed my beloved I'm going to get
you for that then it is the deal with
the knowledge that somebody has left you
even though you're the smartest person
in the galaxy because you're just not
around no matter the reason that you
left so even though Rick's trying to
protect his family this whole time it
would be way more heartbreaking at
Beth's mom left them knowing all the
sacrifices that Rick made so that's
probably one of the reasons why he's so
cynical about the idea of love and
marriage it all goes away Morty it's
just this artificial construct it
doesn't mean anything but you know one
of the biggest things about Rick is that
he lies it's sort of a Doctor Who rule
rule number one the doctor lies Rick why
did you lie to your daughter so I
wouldn't have to come here so regardless
of the way you feel about the pickle
Rick episode I think that does a good
job of showing you the way that Rick
feels about things like really honestly
feels about things so when he's trying
to tell Morty don't fall in love because
it's all [ __ ] you know why he says
stuff like that he's not saying it to be
mean he's saying it because he's become
very cynical because of his own
experience and he'll just say really
messed up things to hide his true
feelings so let me know in the comments
based on all the flashbacks based on the
idea of rupee land and what Beth did
while she was growing up what do you
think happened to Rick's wife do you
think that she's dead in every single
reality or do you think that Rick
actually did something to pray
the Beth rake relationship is such a big
thing on the show it feels like they
could push off introducing a mother and
present day for a while but who knows
they haven't said a whole lot about
whether or not they do it in the future
just that they're not doing it right now
but what will happen is is I'll post my
episode 9 Easter Egg video tomorrow just
like normal leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner Fraga sh
you in one of those art books please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there's a new round in this
video all you have to do tenders just be
a subscriber leave a comment on the
video I'll announce a new winner when I
post that episode 9 video you can click
here for more Rick and Morty and you can
click here for brand new Game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]